russell how are you ah well i feel very
happy to see you there in your new
environment your new
location your largo are you trying to
summons up some ambience
yes yes i'm at the largo theatre which a
theater that you've performed at many
times you're well known here
thank you i apologize for the mess and i
paid as best as i could for the cleaning
don't shine a blue light in that
dressing room
oh but you see you've you've come so far
that's the old russell the scamp the
sexual satyr the um
uh the spirit animal uh free i mean when
i first met you
uh doing doing the late night show in
new york city
i was told that you would arrive i never
met you before i came backstage
you were dressed all in leather and you
were you were prowling
you were a trapped jungle cat and i
remembered
the sensuality and creativity coming off
you the ferocity
uh you could not be tamed look at you
now
you are at peace you are
uh in touch with the universe around you
you appear to be sleeping on a bed
these are all things that can only
happen to a man who's finally found his
inner peace how did you do it
i told you what it is conan perhaps all
evolution is the result of the
relationship between
appetites and environment look at
mythology it's always on about appetite
look at native american
mythology the crow the hair the horny
little trickster
eventually these appetites take you to a
place where you need to change the
appetites can only take you so far
your carnal brutal need for fame and
power as represented by that priapic
phallic guitar behind you even now red
and throbbing like your haircut
it can only take you so far i mean there
aren't many people
in the world who have penis replacement
hairdos
solely you you're like a male medusa
with a single priapic
monolith a unicorn a singular horn
a living lucky charm al conan yes i'm
telling you
first of all russell you're right i've
i've skated as far as i can go
on this absurd pastry that i call hair
you of course see it as a phallic symbol
but then again you see everything
as a phallic symbol uh a guitar suddenly
becomes a
throbbing male member what is an
innocent
childish hairstyle to you becomes a
threatening
male orgasmic
penis i'll say does not we just have to
call it what it is
but i do look up to you so much russell
you're very uh
honestly do you really mean that i don't
know i mentioned all those things i
don't mean to interrupt you particularly
not when you seemed on the brink of
paying me a compliment a shocking thing
in itself remember i'm english and uh
a compliment might bring me to tears
with stuart
still racks with grief in this country
what i'm saying is like that
there is an ulterior realm the material
world the world of things and symbols
is a referent to a deeper reality now
people think this is
you know hocus pocus uh cockamamie new
age
tomfoolery but the fact is that the
senses are limited
our capacity for knowledge is limited
but the potential for information is
limitless
like our cosmos i believe there are
techniques and methods that we can use
ways of directing our appetites and
drives that can bring us to a point of
awakening
that's what i believe i'm not claiming
to be there yet i'm still a strange
person
i'm still wearing these strange strange
socks and feeling these strange strange
feelings
but on a pathway conan i'm on a pathway
with
you you and i your pale clammy hand
in my brown hairy mitt the two of us
walking towards the light of the lord
well okay well let's talk about your
life now you're a very domesticated
fellow now
um you uh you live uh
with your lovely uh wife you have uh
children
and you have lots of animals is that
correct it's like
a farm where there's no end product you
know
like it's like agriculture where at the
end of it you don't have
i don't know wheat or milk or cheese
you just have feces strewn on every
surface
all anyone does in this house is
defecate and create stools from the
kittens to the children
even the adults in fact but according to
protocols we use a latrine that's the
british way
that's how we've held together the
empire all these merry years
and that's why you will still pay taxes
without representation
so like uh yeah it's like a it's like
it's like
like it's like the product is just
excretia conan like
but um yeah i mean i can show you cute
animals i can
leave my um john and yo car yo john and
yoko style bed and
take you on a wander through my humble
home and show you some of the kittens
and stuff
i'm i'm happy to do whatever you want to
do russell you are my guru you are
uh you are my light i look to you
because i think you could be my
salvation i do
i i that is a heavy burden for anyone to
bear
the idea of cleansing your soul you'd
need a hell of a lot of bleach and some
thick rubber gloves
but i'm up for the job